vengers endgame we finally have the
title and we finally got the first
teaser trailer for Avengers endgame
how's it going everybody it's Warren and
now that the title is out and the first
teaser trailer is out some of the actors
in the movie can finally speak out just
a little bit about the movie obviously
avengers end games going to be a movie
that is kept well under wraps even more
than the previous Marvel movies so
nobody is obviously going to go too much
into detail but they can't speak a
little bit about it now and in a recent
interview Karen Gillan who plays nebula
has recently opened up a little bit to
people while speaking about Thanos in
the interview she said what can I say
Danna says her dad and she is definitely
going to confront some serious daddy
issues that's for sure nebula has been
expected for a very long time to play a
key part in defeating Thanos she's
Thanos his daughter although she was
kidnapped and kind of forced to be his
daughter she's still fan owes his
daughter and was raised by him and she
knows more about him than anyone that is
currently alive in the MCU so she's
obviously going to play a big role in
defeating him and not to mention she
plays a really big role in the comics as
well in the comics she manages to take
the Infinity Gauntlet away from Thanos
and not only does she manage to take it
away from him she actually undos the
snap so she's strong enough but more
importantly she has enough will to wield
the Infinity Gauntlet and not only that
she manages to take on and defeat the
cosmic entities in the comics so she
plays a pretty big role in the Infinity
Gauntlet comic series and it sounds like
she's going to play a pretty big role in
Avengers in game as well judging off
what she told people and we already know
from the guardians of the galaxy movies
that she desperately wants to defeat
Thanos for turning her into what she is
after Xander
you're going to kill my father you dare
to oppose me you see money is cheer me
into you kill him I will help you
destroy a thousand planets so I think we
can expect a pretty good fight scene
between her and Thanos especially since
he's kind of in a weakened state right
now and probably won't have all of the
Infinity stones
who knows maybe she'll even end up
wielding the Infinity Gauntlet in
avengers endgame
she's clearly going to play a big part
and she's clearly going to end up
confronting Thanos let me know what you
all think is going to happen in Avengers
end game when nebula takes on Thanos you
think she'll stand a chance and do you
think she'll wield the Infinity Gauntlet
let me know your thoughts in the
comments down below and don't forget
about my giveaway I'm giving away a
life-sized Infinity Gauntlet if you'd
like to enter for your chance to win all
you have to do is be subscribed to my
channel like this video and comment down
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero as always thank you
all so much for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]
you